hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another q a
for anyone who wants to ask questions
for the next one you basically just
leave the questions in the comments of
this one
and then next month i will look at them
my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
rather than having youtube's randomly
selected ads cut me off
in the middle of a sentence to the
questions
okay i'm gonna actually edit these two
to be at the start of the video and this
is what we're gonna use for our headline
because
this line of questioning is so common
even though i feel like i've addressed
this
like so blatantly so the first one is
what's your favorite thing about being a
games journalist
and reviewer i am not a games
journalist or a reviewer i haven't been
for years
i stopped calling myself anything along
the lines of games journalists the
minute that i left ign where i was a
games journalist you know that was
part of my job was reaching out to devs
to studios to getting interviews to
trying to
actually get information as is in line
with the practice of journalism
but as soon as i left ign which was
three
years ago four years ago uh i no longer
consider myself that at all i have not
reviewed a game on this channel
for three years the last one was uh the
no man's sky update
but outside of that not a games
journalist
i certainly talk about that stuff and
like you know go on podcasts and have
conversations about video games but i
am a video game writer that means i am
writing a video game in the game
development
side of the industry i get comments
where people are wrong about this so
often that i'm like we're just gonna
answer it right now make it a headline
link it to anyone who asks going forward
just like it's an official statement i'm
sure that like no matter what when
you've worked in a certain facet of the
industry for a long time even though i
again i feel like i haven't for ages
like technically i was doing games media
and inside gaming but even then i didn't
actually feel like i was didn't consider
myself a journalist by any means
but yeah when people know you for one
thing and then the thing
changes or the part of the industry
changes i can get why you know people
can't be caught up to speed if they
watch every video or read every tweet or
anything like that it's not their fault
for uh not knowing the update maybe it's
on me i need to say it way
more blatantly my favorite thing about
being a games journalist and reviewer
actually when i
used to be was visiting studios and
getting to talk to devs and seeing how
different games are made
getting to uh you know interview all the
developers that i had access to to learn
different things about video games which
is obviously a skill that i'm using now
that i work in game development it's
probably going to be very weird for me
when i get interviewed
about game develop that's going to be
very strange
i hadn't even thought about that until
now that eventually there could be
somebody doing like what i did with ign
coming to my studio and asking me about
video game writing
wild but yeah that was always it was
meeting
these extremely talented people who are
at the absolute top of their field and
and having them just like share their
expertise with me was
uh incredible and to get to do that all
over the world as well
i really love learning i really [ __ ]
love video games so that was my favorite
part of it
so the second question is why did you
leave games media was it issues with
corruption or tokenism or what
um i've also obviously spoken about this
um
you know if i make this headline i
probably will make it why did i leave
games media i also just want to say
people will definitely comment about me
using why i left or why this person left
in a youtube headline it's a common
question that's generally how i pick the
titles for any of the q and a's is
literally just
the most common question is the one that
i will make the headline because it
means the most people
are looking for the answer to that
question and this is absolutely the most
common question that i've gotten from
the bunch
that we are answering today in any case
um i left games media because i wanted
to write a video game i definitely don't
think
games media is perfect i have added uh
the most common criticism that i have of
games media is that i think a lot of
writers write for each other
and not for their audiences but it is
also extremely hard to write something
for
the general public because there are so
many people with so many different
opinions it's like you can't just cater
something to
an impossible invisible mass uh because
there's just so many facets of that mass
but
yeah i mean i think there are some uh
things that i take
ethical issue with definitely not a
contributing factor why i wanted to move
on
um tokenism wasn't either i've seen
people say that they thought that i left
ign because of the way that they were
treating me on camera i
aired a thing where when i was making
one particular show for ign i found it
very
dis disheartening because like you know
i
studied journalism i was hired at ign as
a writer and then
these particular execs came in and i did
this particular job
that was not technically my job i was
still an editorial producer and a writer
but they were having me as a host and i
just remembered being at this event and
trying to take notes in my notebook
and having them tell me to put my
notebook down so they can like fix my
hair and my makeup so they could film me
and i think i was the only female
journalist in the room trying to take
notes on a video game and i just like
was so
grossed out by that but that same show
also like just the way they did my
makeup and my hair and
you know i was like kind of
uncomfortable with a lot of facets of
that and it wasn't what i wanted to do
for a living
but that didn't contribute to me leaving
because that was just this one small
stint of a thing that i just never would
have done again when i was like can i
just do my makeup myself
um which related i've been getting so
much better at makeup lately
i think because of quarantine i'm so
[ __ ] bored of seeing my own face
that like i started wearing makeup
i like it a lot it's really fun um in
any case yeah i asked if i could do it
myself because i felt like they were
like putting too much makeup on me like
i don't
tend to wear really any foundation i
don't like the cakey
look or the feel of it and the answer
was something like
that showbiz tell her she has to suck it
up i was like but you get to control the
way that i look
i didn't sign up for this i was hired as
a writer
so i yeah so i disliked that but that
was again one really small facet of a
really small thing
with a very small group of people it was
not a larger issue
uh ign were generally very respectful of
my editorial voice and of me as a writer
um it's a place a lot of people leave
because you don't get paid very much and
you have crazy expectations and it's
also like
a very just a big company it means that
there are a lot of things going on that
it can be
very overwhelming and it can feel like
everything is on fire all the time
but i also have a lot of friends who
still work there that i'm very close to
i still work with them on a frequent
basis i
would say i've been consulting for them
on their charity stream so i'm helping
them out
basically with their ongoing charity
streams i think i've had an input in all
of them
um kind of on a production side so i do
still work with ign closely
and have a lot of friends there but i
left the
short if it all like those are like
little tiny pieces i left because
i wanted to write a video game i really
had learned everything there was to
learn in games media
i i was at the biggest company in terms
of gays media
oh that's a frozen webcam
wow i love that for me look how shocked
i look
wow oh
and now we're really zoomed in for some
reason
okay that seems good
i don't know i left games media because
i didn't want to do it anymore
um and then i felt like i had learned
everything i was already at the biggest
company
uh in you know the really one of the
biggest roles that i could get to there
i had really already done all the things
that i
wanted to do in that field i didn't feel
like there was any room for growth like
sure i could have gotten promoted
um and i was promoted while i worked at
ign but that to me isn't like
actual human growth that's just a new
job title and some more money so it just
i just didn't feel like there was really
anything left for me to do and you know
my two passions in life have always been
video games and writing and i had always
written fiction my whole life and i had
worked on some scripted content even at
ign and the places i had worked before i
joined as a writer
so i moved to rooster teeth who i guess
like effectively poached me like they
reached out to me and
and tried to get me to work with them
and that was exciting to me because they
do
film tv animation and games so there was
opportunity for me to write on
a bunch more creative stuff heading in
the direction that i have headed to that
i you know spoke about even while i was
working at rooster teeth uh was that i
wanted to
write a video game and so that's what
i'm doing today
and i think that answers the two
questions we've done it it's time
to talk about keeps did you know that
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left
of course if you want to if you don't
already know you used to have to go to
the doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your home
they make it easy and deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor visits keeps also
offers generic versions of the only two
fda approved hair loss products
out there you might have tried them
before but probably never for this price
keeps treatments typically take between
four to six months to see results so
it's important to act
fast basically the sooner you start
using keeps the more of your hair
you can save so find out why keeps has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors and why
hundreds and thousands of men trust
keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication if you're
ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
alana pierce or click the link in the
description to receive 50 off your first
order that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
a-l-a-n-a-h-p-e-a-r-c-e
and now back to the video derek clark
asks for the next q a when do you feel
done playing a game do you feel the need
to see the ending does it vary by genre
um it definitely depends on the game so
i've gotten better in recent years about
not finishing things
if i'm not super into them i used to you
know
make sure that i would finish every game
even if i didn't like it that much but
now there are just too many games and i
want to play more of them
rather than you know necessarily finish
something that i'm not enjoying
i do like experiencing virtually every
aaa release so i can at least
speak to it i won't necessarily finish
all of them um but when i feel done
playing a game yeah totally depends on
the game like right now
i've been playing like very slowly this
game called the falconeo which is
currently on gamepass
i really like it did not expect to like
it but i'm super into it and
just because of how much i've enjoyed
playing that game i'm going for the
thousand game of school and that's just
because i was like i want more time out
of this
um i very rarely do that i will like
address the achievements or trophies
list and be like okay
how simple are these going to be or is
this just going to suck because i
hate collectible based achievement but
if it doesn't have that and it's stuff
that like sounds like it would be fun
for me to do
i will effectively make a game i already
like longer
by chasing down the achievements so i'm
doing that with that game right now and
i won't feel done playing that game
until i've done that
but generally it's just finishing the
main campaign i don't necessarily do all
the side quests i i feel like i just
approach it organically it's like
however much i want to get out of the
game is what i'll get out of it
i don't try to put any pressure on
myself with that kind of thing but noy
said do you have a go-to genre of music
you enjoy more than most and who be your
favorite musical act
my go-to genre of music that i enjoy
more than most
is post hardcore um
which a lot of it's really nostalgic and
a lot of like
emo stuff like i really like a day to
remember
breaking benjamin sleeping with sirens
just bands that i really liked listening
to in high school because i was
an emo kid my favorite actual artist
like full stop of all time though is
childish gambino who
even childish gambino i feel like covers
a lot of different genres of music and i
love
every genre that he has dabbled in oh
just to better said what's your favorite
survival horror game
i've spoken at length about survival
horror being one of my favorite genres
and i'm very excited about resident evil
i do plan to actually
we'll see if the time works out i am
basically in time crunch right now
because i'm going back to australia
pretty soon and i have
so much to do before i go but i'm
planning to do actual like proper
youtube playthroughs of resident evil 8
village
we'll see hopefully i never do that for
games like so rarely but
that's the plan but my favorite survival
horror game is also my favorite game
ever
which is deadly premonition it's not a
game that i would recommend to most
people i'm not going to tell you it's
good
but i will say it's not a game i love
ironically people always think that
no i actually love the hell
out of deadly premonition i have a
deadly premonition tattoo
etc i love it i'm also a really big fan
of silent hill 2. silent hill pt
uh i think is absolutely fantastic even
though a lot of people will argue that
it's not a game
it is shut up it being a playable teaser
demo does it
it it's standalone it didn't okay you
can plug holes in it but shut up
this is a very nice question elisa
carmendova said where would you prefer
people watch your gameplay videos
meaning
which platform views have eventually
more value i used to watch your live
streams here on youtube but since you're
partnered on twitch i most have been
watching your streams there
um i don't really mind uh
because i don't really care about making
money
on youtube and twitch because it's not
my job um it doesn't really matter i
would say
probably watching on youtube is more
helpful if it's on my main
channel because it's better for
discovery purposes but
hey you do you the fact that you want to
watch it at all and that you're offering
to do that is very kind of you
you don't have to do any of that don't
worry about it ryan sheeran said what is
a piece of australian slang and
non-aussie can use to spice up their
day-to-day conversations always love the
content keep up the great work
the one that i like the most that i try
to use but obviously is out in my vocab
just because i don't hear people say it
is on your bike which is just telling
somebody to [ __ ] off
just it's just on your bike mate it's
literally just get out
which i guess it's the equivalent to
saying like get on your bike and leave
um on your bike i'm a big fan of that
one i like that a lot
i'm not here to [ __ ] spiders it's
probably most people's
favorite one uh which is like does a pop
[ __ ] in the woods it would be like if
somebody you're at a restaurant somebody
asked you if you're ready to get dinner
you'd be like yes obviously i'm not here
to [ __ ] spiders what do you think i was
here for
i don't use that so much but that is a
common foreign favorite
if you want to adopt that one knighthood
asks the most important question remains
unanswered
crepes waffles or pancakes i love all
three
and they're all good for different moods
all right sometimes
i'm trying to [ __ ] around i need a crepe
it's tidy
you put the things inside the crepe
there's not too many toppings there's
this place that i
loved in san francisco [ __ ] what's it
called
i'm devastated that i'm forgetting the
name of this
cafe but they would make like savory
crepes so you could get like spinach
chicken and cheese and i would often get
those
in an ig and lunch break too just it's
so easy to eat you know it's
contain and you don't it doesn't have to
be the nutella chocolate situation
pancakes great for breakfast i like
waffles better for dessert
actually all good depending on the time
of day
that's my answer peace out i also just
did want to
um address
a bunch of
comments that i saw so the last q a the
title was while never do only fans
and you know i said the reason for that
for anyone who missed it is basically
i don't like having my picture taken
that means like it's it's not something
that i hate i'm not i'm not saying that
um but it is not something i would ever
want to have to spend a long time doing
you know i'll post a selfie on instagram
uh it's obviously not
much of my instagram feed
i've got one two three four five
posts between the last two pictures of
me and then between that it's one two
three four
five six seven like literally seven
posts in a row
that i'm not even in on my own instagram
not a person who feels comfortable
having their picture taken for several
hours you know if it's
just one picture and then we're running
off fine with it anyway that's that's a
side note
it's not that i'm against it it's just
something that i would never want to
spend time doing and i feel like i was
pretty clear about that that like i
don't have problem with people doing
only fans i'm in support of people
making that content i'm sure for a lot
of people they find it very fun they
like being sexually expressive or
feeling sexy like
they enjoy the posing for photos thing
what i was gonna say is uh
i did get a lot of comments of people
saying things like um
and these weren't questions just
comments that i just kind of wanted to
talk about
of people saying like i'm so glad you
said you wouldn't do and only fans
only people who don't have self-respect
do that and i just kind of wanted to air
an opinion let me see if i can find one
of these just so i can read it out
so this is a pretty polite one but let
me um let me read this out anyway this
person said don't get me wrong i'd be
first in line believe me if you did
thank you but i'm actually glad you're
not
um first of all the goodies aren't for
everybody and secondly you're a rare
breed and a woman of morale
and actually has some self-respect for
yourself and in today's
day and age that's so rare and
personally gets mad respect from me
kudos i like you even more now if that's
possible but you get the point
thank you um sorry he also said a woman
that knows her self-worth in class is
akibo
so this is a very nice way to phrase
this full of compliments thank you
but um there were a lot like this and
some that were a little bit harsher uh
not towards me but to
the people who do make content on only
fans and i just really want to add the
opinion
um of course you don't have to agree
with me but it's just something that i
wanted to say
i don't think that someone choosing to
make and only fans and share that kind
of content
means that they don't respect themselves
you can respect yourself completely and
just
enjoy you know feeling sexy feeling
attractive being sexually expressive
um i don't think human bodies should be
things that we're ashamed of
or ashamed of sharing it doesn't mean
that you don't
respect yourself it doesn't mean you
deserve less respect
you could just enjoy existing that way
and expressing yourself that way
i know that this is like really common
rhetoric that people say this um
but yeah i just don't think it means you
don't have respect for yourself i would
think not having respect for yourself is
stuff like not looking after your body
like not eating the right foods not not
exercising not
treating yourself the way that you
should to make sure that you are happy
and fulfilled and i just don't see the
correlation between
someone having and only fans and
enjoying taking pictures
regardless of who's buying them i don't
think that matters
and self-respect and that's the thing
that you know i just kind of want to
throw out there is a thing worth
considering if you haven't before that
i don't think there is any real reason
to see any less of someone
um because they won't do this and so
while i did get a lot of
comments that are technically
compliments and have gotten them my
whole career people being like
you know you're one of the good ones
because you don't show cleavage you're
not a [ __ ] you don't
stream with cleavage or have cleavage in
youtube videos
that is not a self-respect thing um so i
always
i'm like that this compliment doesn't
feel nice it just kind of feels like
you're insulting
other people for something i don't think
that they necessarily deserve that kind
of judgment for
so you know being like yeah you're one
of the good ones you won't do this and i
certainly never will do it it is
literally never going to happen i would
really not have a fun time i never want
to
earn money for something that i don't
enjoy like it's i don't care about money
like i'm not
i'm not doing it i just don't want the
compliment for not doing it i don't
think there's anything wrong with other
people doing it i don't think it makes
them bad people i
don't think it makes them lesser and i i
don't know just want to throw it out
there
for anyone who hasn't thought about it
that way and that is it for me today
everyone
uh remember that you can check the link
in the description to find out more
about keeps
and otherwise i will see you guys next
month bye